In South Korea, the Constitutional Court...
...formally removes the country's impeached president, Park Geun-hye, from office.
In Russia, President Vladimir Putin...
...says that Russian-Turkish relations are strengthening...
...as the two countries seek ways to reduce the scale of fighting in Syria.
In Nigeria, President Muhammadu Buhari returns home...
...after nearly two months of medical leave in Britain.
In the US, members of the Standing Rock Sioux nation and indigenous leaders...
...hold a rally in Washington, DC, to protest the Dakota Access Pipeline.
And finally, experts unearth one of Egypt's most important ever archaeological discoveries:...
...an eight-meter statue depicting pharaoh Ramses the Great.